find your gut just go with your gut I
trust my gut
what's up believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference now I watch a lot of videos
we do a lot of top tens a lot of rules
that come up over and over and over and
over again so the goal of this series is
to combine together the rules that keep
coming up consistently and smoosh them
into one video just for you so today
we're gonna learn how can you follow
your gut feeling also if you want to
hear our Mel Robbins myself and Lisa
Nichols have to say about building
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every morning
for the next 250 for mornings for
absolutely free I will send you a 30
second to 5 minute video to help you
build unstoppable confidence check out
the link in the description below I know
that everybody's problem comes down to
one pattern you're repeating that you
can't see and that pattern is getting
triggered by something that happened in
your past that left you with this
emotional scar surround yourself with
greatness if you want to be more
confident you need to surround yourself
with things that make you feel confident
that give you boldness and make you want
to do something big and new and special
and different and want to actually
follow through on it if you look at the
people in your life right now do they
give you confidence does your mom give
you confidence and your friends give you
confidence you know do your teachers or
colleagues give you confidence or when
you tell them your idea that they say
that it's a stupid idea and you
shouldn't do it does your office or
bedroom give you confidence in the
videos you watch give you confidence
right all of that matters so many times
we we we validate who we are by what
we're doing for other people you know we
who we are is what we do what we give
how we love and what I'm very clear on
is that you are giving the world an
example of
they get to love you and treat you based
on the way you love and treat yourself I
[Music]
mean when I was 22 right after I
graduated from Dartmouth I was so
focused on making everyone happy that I
almost chose the worst possible career
for my personality it's not a bad career
it just would have been horrendous for
me I was interested in the environment
so I decided oh you know I'll go get a
law degree and then I'll go work in
Washington and I think maybe I'll work
on environmental policy and I'd probably
end up in some cube farm and everyone
was thrilled with the plan everyone it
turns out but me so here I am I'm
driving a u-haul across country to go to
law school and to get a degree in
environmental law and something started
to gnaw at me and with every single mile
that I drove my thoughts were getting
louder and doubts were starting to pour
in my gut was telling me Mel
turn the damn u-haul around but the
problem was that everything was already
in place right I mean I'm already in the
u-haul the thing is already packed I'm
already 10 miles into my drive the
tuition had been paid for the first
semester I had signed a lease I mean I
could not undo these things
isn't that why it's so difficult for you
to make changes in your life because you
think that things can't be undone the
fact is any excuse that you come up with
you can undo tuition can be reimbursed
apartments can be leased Plan B can be
invented so I got up I repack that
u-haul and I drove out of town
I let myself make a u-turn in life if
you ever find your gut battling your
head save yourself the drama I guarantee
you your gut is right guarantee you your
excuses can be undone and I guarantee
you you can make a u-turn in your life
right now if you want to how you drove
mr. De Niro my name is Bradley
my question is regarding awakenings I
wanted desperately to ask a question I
was terrified and I wanted to ask this
specific random question about
awakenings and right before I came to my
because I you have to say before they
once when they passed you the mic so I I
thought oh this is gonna be a stupid
question and he's gonna say why would
you ask that stupid question and and so
I thought I'll just ask some question
about the mission and riding a horse and
then and then somebody would have been
asked a question about the mission right
before I had my question oh no and the
next thing I know it's my turn I'm
standing up and I'm looking at my idol
across you know 40 30 feet away and then
I just asked the question that I wanted
to about awakenings and and he said good
question mm-hmm
and and it like blew me away and I
thought it was just a little reminder
but you know just go with your gut you
know there's a reason why you think the
way you do and and and want to do the
things you do and you just can't let
anybody tell you don't do it but
especially you don't allow you to tell
you not to do it yeah the Ovilus voice
that that's a contrarian is usually me
and you know all these little moments of
confirmation that that voice should just
shut up allows you to just do what
you're supposed to do while you're here
what does it take in the brain what kind
of control does it take from the brain
the mind over the body to go into
extremes as I've been shown like you
going climbing Mount Everest to the
Death Zone in shorts or going to record
distances under the eyes or standing for
two hours in eyes directly contact what
kind of mind control do you need to be
able to do that that's what I learnt to
do through trial and error just by
following my feeling so I felt good and
good good feeling is like connection
connection of are of the mind over the
body that feels good that actually is a
way to learn to bring up your psyche
control and that is what is needed in a
very extreme situation where an
ice-water is
taking place but actually I took the ice
water environment to learn to deal with
my mind in connection with the body when
you want to learn how to trust your
intuition more you know I say and this
is me and my walk and my belief system
that your intuition is your internal GPS
system your internal God placement
system
it's that whisper and sometimes it's
that scream that tells you to leap or to
be still your intuition is a combination
of spirit emotion and logic and it's
guiding you and so often we don't hear
our intuition why don't we hear it
because we're having too much chatter in
our head like the chatter in our head
doubt worry judgment oh my god judgment
are fear fear of other people's
perception of you so your intuition is
saying I love to dance I want to dance I
want to sing your intuition is saying we
can have a great time your intuition
said I want love your intuition is
saying gosh let's go take that chance on
that writing that book or let's take
that chance on starting that business
then your chatter comes in know what if
I fail so let me explain this to you
your mind your brain is designed to keep
you safe it's designed and it only has
the ability to go back in time in the
mental file cabinet and look at the last
time you tried something like this and
it may not have been good or it may have
ended in some dangerous situations where
people could judge you and your brain is
designed to protect you that's it your
brains desire to protect you is logical
your intuition is that spark of passion
it's that spark of desire it's that
spark of love it's that spark of pull me
forward it's that little bit of radical
it's that a lot a bit of I want to leave
my fingerprint on this planet your brain
isn't designed to have those same IDs
now now your intuition can kick the
brain in and the brain can start
thinking of ways to but the intuition is
where it's gonna start it's in your gut
it see this is why when you feel
something you kind of go here you don't
go oh I feel so special you don't say I
feel special here you say I feel it here
I feel it here and so your job is not to
turn down the doubt your job is to turn
up the passion it's to turn up the faith
is to turn up the possibility now still
make well-thought-out plan I always say
the best plan is the plan made I don't
care if you have to upgrade it you have
to modify it but if you if you if you if
you fail to plan then you plan to fail
so every dream every passion every
desire follow it with the plan cuz
that's where your brain gets excited
your brain goes yeah we got a plan now
now you can believe yourself see you set
big goals and dreams and you have
desires and then you don't achieve it
but you don't achieve it because you
didn't set the plan in place you didn't
do the details and then you stopped
believing you could do it then you do
the biggest tragedy you stopped dreaming
you stopped hoping you stopped
stretching yourself you stop listening
to your GPS your god placement system
that says you've been put here on a
divine assignment and your assignment
may change over years guess what your
assignment you had 50 years ago may be
very different from the assignment on
your life today your job is to turn down
the volume in your head the volume of
judgment the volume of fear the volume
of worry the volume of perfection turned
down the volume in your head and turn up
the volume in your interval
then your solar plex in that God
placement system in that heart space
turn up the volume that place there just
says what if I want what
ask yourself this tonight today tomorrow
what feel good tomorrow and then be
still and be quiet the experience that
you get gut is a barometer of experience
it's not just an emotional thing it's
something that comes from the ongoing
experience that you get from doing the
thing that you're trying to do I love
using my gut as a factor in me making
the decisions especially the big ones
because logic yes has its place but if
you're making decisions just based on
what's logical then you're living in a
world that currently exists and part of
what we do as entrepreneurs is we're
trying to create something new right the
world will evolve and change without you
the logic that exists right now will not
be in place in 25 years and 10 years and
five years maybe even next year and so
if you're making decisions only base top
logic you're living in the past and that
can serve you but it's definitely not
the complete picture with every
especially major decision that you're
make you want to make sure that you feel
it that even if it doesn't work out even
if you fail it's worth knowing I had
this experience when I was 18 years old
that fundamentally rocked my life I was
in Paris I wanted to ask this girl out
end of the day I was too afraid and I
took a picture and I posted on my wall
of the scenery and I looked at that
every day as a reminder to myself that
the next time I wanted to do something I
would have the courage to push through
the fear push for the potential failure
and do it and that inspired me to the
next year when I had my chance to have
my own software company or go get these
super high-paying jobs which one would I
regret potentially not doing what does
my gut tell me to do and my gut told me
I need to at least try this thing I'm
able to work I mean really amazing and
luckily it worked out but maybe it'll
flame up maybe it won't work maybe will
this be a terrible decision maybe I've
just wasted a year of my life trying
this thing
and I was okay with that because at
least I knew where I think a lot of
people we have a gut feeling on
something you have a gut feeling what
you want to do you have a gut response
to how you want to deal with situation
but you don't listen to it and you do
the only logical thing to do and you
live your entire life in the safe lane
you're never going to accomplish
anything great because again you're just
living according to the rules of the
past and so the next time you get that
feeling do the thing that you got tells
you to do you could do what I did where
I had that failure moment right that not
listening to my gut not listening to my
intuition taking a picture put it on my
wall as that visual reminder you could
do something similar think of an
opportunity missed think of a chance of
an idea that you had and put that visual
on your wall somewhere so you look at it
daily as a constant reminder because
these ideas that you have somebody else
is going to make millions of dollars off
of them if you don't and you have no
right in five years to say that was my
idea he made millions
she made millions and I'm still stuck
here where I was in the same place five
years ago you have no right to complain
about it because it's your fault because
you didn't take the action on it because
you didn't listen to your gut so whether
you have a visual reminder whether you
write something down on a piece of paper
whether this video just inspires that
for you the next time you have that
feeling in your gut that this feels
right whether this feels wrong or that
you just need to know then learn to
listen to it
recently I was with a bunch of other
investors of I respect and they brought
me a deal and I wanted to be part of it
but it didn't feel right and I wrote
millions of dollars on that one and it
just didn't feel right and I lost it all
within two years
so should investors trust their got
dinner absolutely and trust you well
what about you said earlier don't be
emotional and sometimes the gut no this
is a barometer of risk it's something an
internalized for an investor that says I
don't feel comfortable it's not about
emotions just don't write that check
that was recently the first time I
didn't listen to that and I lost
everything so now my
radar is up I listen to my gut
it's not an emotion it's an index of
risk and you get it as you age you
become a better investor every year if
only I could live to 200 I'd be really
good well at the end of the day if you
really break it down it's all based on
passion it's all based on how you feel I
don't want to get involved into anything
unless I am you know emotionally
committed and connected to the project I
trust my gut I trust like how I feel
about something so you know if you asked
my business manager how I do my
investing he'll tell you that it's like
lopsided you know like I don't I take
bigger risks and with the bulk of my
money instead of like putting my money
in like very conservative places you
know like I'm like well I like never
seen this much money before in my life
and I made it all myself so the best
part about it for me is I can make the
decision of where it goes sometimes it
might not be the wisest decision but I
made that money so I have every right to
do with it too you know whatever way I
would choose so that's another thing
about the the idea of working for
yourself and and actually making your
own money
you're not owing anyone anything about
you so that way so for me if I am going
to invest my money in my time into these
projects I have to be 100% certain that
I'm so emotionally engaged and a part of
the project that if it fails it's still
you know it doesn't matter to me because
I I feel validity with the amount of
time and investment that I put into it
well I love college because I knew
exactly what I wanted to do and some of
you know too but some of you don't or
maybe you thought you knew but are now
questioning that choice maybe you're
sitting there trying to figure out how
to tell your parents that you want to be
a doctor and not a comedy writer
well what you choose to do next is what
we call in the movies the character
defining moment now these are moments
you version while you're with like in
the last Star Wars the first force
awakens
when Rey realizes the force is with her
or Indiana Jones choosing mission over
fear by jumping into a pile of snakes
now on a two-hour movie you get a
handful of character defining moments
but in real life you face them every day
life is one straw a strong long string
of character defining moments and I was
lucky that at 18 I knew what I exactly
wanted to do but I didn't know who I was
I
how could I and how could any of us
because for the first 25 years of our
lives we are trained to listen to voices
that are not our own parents and
professors fill our heads with wisdom
and information and then employers and
mentors take their place and explain how
this world really works and usually
these voices of authority makes sense
but sometimes doubt starts to creep into
our heads and into our hearts and even
when we think that's not quite how I see
the world it's kind of easier just to
nod in agreement and go along and for a
while I let that going along to find my
character because I was repressing my
own point of view because like in that
Nilsson song everybody was talking at me
so I couldn't hear the echoes of my mind
and at first the internal voice I needed
to listen to was hardly audible and it
was hardly noticeable kind of like me in
high school but then I started paying
more attention and my intuition kicked
in and I want to be clear that your
intuition is different from your
conscience they work in tandem but
here's the distinction your conscience
shouts here's what you should do while
your intuition whispers here's what you
could do listen to that voice that tells
you what you could do nothing will
define your character more than that
because once I turned to my intuition
and I tuned into it I certain projects
began to pull me into them and others I
turned away from one of the things you
said this is going to be close to a
direct quote the most important thing
that you could cultivate is the ability
to listen to your intuition yes so how
do you cultivate that self-awareness is
huge like that that monologue just went
on about all of the steps that I took to
be able to self-reflect and does it
start from like a feeling it's certainly
there's always a feeling and that's the
thing that we are told we are taught to
ignore feelings and we've done a
terrible job culturally not just in the
US but in the West we've done a very bad
job of cultivating one's desire
expectation ability to listen to our
intuition and it was you know we all
have different paths some through sort
of grief some through achievement some
through struggle to start to listen to
we all have that compass when I first
started making videos I was originally
collecting vintage clips of exotic
places that I considered to be beautiful
and inspiring and started setting it to
classical music
and then I eventually started setting
those clips to my own music and slowly
splicing myself in turning them into
music videos I knew in my video for
video games I wanted to feature
different clips of the chateaux because
it was one of the most beautiful places
that we had seen in Hollywood and it had
a lot of the muted blues and greens that
I was sort of inspired by for the color
scheme of my video I actually started
with the footage from here and then
started collecting my other footage for
the video based on I don't know the
energy and the colors that I found some
vintage clips of the Chateau back about
10 years ago I used a collection of
different clips some of them were some
of them were vintage clips from the 50s
and 60s of certain icons or just shots
of things that I considered to be really
beautiful and timeless and I also
spliced in different footage of more
modern clips of kids skateboarding down
in Santa Monica and also you know like
there's a modern-day actress and that I
put in the video and I feel like all the
choices I made were really they were
just personal choices I was guided by my
intuition and I just picked things that
I thought were beautiful
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from george RR martin on how to follow
your gut that i think you're really
gonna enjoy but before that i have three
questions for you i want to make sure
we're moving from not just watching
another video but to actually taking
action reflecting and applying this
video to your life in your business so
three questions for you
think about them write them down
yourself share them with a friend in the
discussion or leave them in the comments
below here we go question number one do
you think you actually do a good job
listening to your gut question number
two what is your intuition telling you
that you are not listening to right now
and question number three what is the
biggest lesson that you have learned
through trial and error thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon and enjoy the bonus
David Benioff and Dan Weiss are the
showrunners you know I don't have any
veto power
you know I signed a pretty standard
contract where I gave them rights to to
adapt us into a television series and I
got certain titles and and the agreement
I had write one script a year and and a
large dump truck full of money and they
can do you know they can have the aliens
come down next season they can turn the
old cast into vampires and I'm powerless
to stop them but I I don't think they
they will do that
they love the books and they're they
seem committed to telling my story in a
different medium and I knew all that
before I signed any of the contracts I
mean when these books started hitting
the New York Times bestseller list which
was as early as Clash of Kings I was
approached by other people who wanted to
adapt them many for feature films and I
had meetings with those people and you
know heard their plans how are they
gonna fit this giant thing in a feature
film well we're gonna make it a little
bet on snow and we'll drop all these are
the characters or we'll make it all
about Danny and we'll drop all these are
the characters I they had various
schemes or of how they would do it or
well we'll just make we'll just make the
first book up to this point and then you
know we hope that the movie will do well
after the order second movie and and
none of these really appealed to me so I
said no which is it's always said that
no is the sexiest word you could say in
Hollywood the the the more you say no
the more they want you and I I guess I
was true because they kept coming and
eventually David and Dan came and we had
a wonderful meeting that lasted like
most of the day we met for lunch and and
you know we were talking and getting all
animated
about how we're gonna do series over
lunch and in a crowded restaurant in Los
Angeles and little by little it emptied
out and pretty soon we were the only
people there you're not drinking our
seventh cup of coffee and iced tea and
still talking about it and and then more
hours passed and we're still talking in
the restaurant to dinner crowd is coming
in and they're setting up for dinner I
think we closed that restaurant that
night so it was one of those classic
meetings that you only get once in a
while but I had a great feeling about
them I mean you know if you're JK
Rowling you can go into a situation
where every studio in Hollywood want you
and you can set very stringent terms
where you get to approve everything but
I'm if you're not JK Rowling and
virtually nobody is JK Rowling except
for JK Rowling then you you can't do
that and you have to find people that
you trust and put your faith in in them
and in the understanding of the story
altruistic world domination honey Empire
right I'm grateful I understand why I'm
here I think because I am so open I
wanted to think unseen it's a bloody
brief life all of you have the potential
for enormous success if you want to know
what Gary Vee DJ Khalid Oprah and others
know about empire building that most
people miss check out the link in the
description for a free bonus video